hi again here's another tutorial for you
guys who have been who have recently
switched from windows xp to windows
vista uh you may have noticed that in
windows explorer for example they have
gotten rid of the file edit view
all those buttons in windows explorer
in order to get those back there's an
extremely almost ridiculously simple
solution hit the alt button
and there they are
it'll
pull up the exact same uh the exact same
buttons that you had before now they
only last for one click so if i go file
and i hit file again it'll disappear
so
if i hit alt it'll bring up anything you
want to do if you want to select all
that's all you have to do you don't have
to control click constantly the entire
thing or try to drag and try not to mess
up
but it'll disappear a second you're done
so
that that is a very useful tip that i
found that if you just hit ex if you
just hit the alt button real quick it'll
pull up uh the help and the tools file
edit view
all these menus that we were used to in
windows xp
and just dispose of them that quickly
now a lot of people are probably going
to ask if this works in microsoft word
so i'm going to open for you word 2007
just to give this a shot and i found out
that hitting alt actually does not it
brings up a number of keyboard shortcuts
so you can follow
um which is really not
um the same as
the the ribbon will stay for now but
i'll try to find you guys a way to
change or to just add those menus to
word 2007 or just office 07 in general
um
but it's really neat that you can
actually just hit the alt button once
and it'll it'll come up with the file
and edit and view and all these menus in
windows vista so um
i hope that was helpful to you guys uh
if you like it just subscribe more
videos to come
and uh thanks for watching peace